experten ist es gelungen die noch im
frachter war kaffee verbliebenen 18.000
tonnen schweröl aus dem wrack in ein
tankschiff zu pumpen bevor das
havarierte schiff zerbricht
weiteres öl kann nun nicht mehr
austreten eine noch größer werdende
ölpest wurde vermieden
mehr als 1000 tonnen giftiges schweröl
sind aus dem frachter bereits ins meer
geflossen nachdem der auf ein
korallenriff vor der küste des insel
barra dieses gelaufen war
verzweifelt kämpften inselbewohner mit
schaufeln eimern und teilweise auch
selbst gebastelten barrieren gegen die
schlammigen ölmassen bis zu 10 km
mangroven sind nach einschätzung von
experten allerdings verseucht die
menschen sind wütend und werden es eine
ganze weile bleiben werden erst
aufräumen mit seinem die
verantwortlichen kümmern
normalerweise hätte das schiff nicht
ohne erlaubnis in dieses gebiet
einfahren dürfen
die küstenwache hat ihre pflichten
vernachlässigt indem sie das schiff
nicht kontrolliert hat und wenn shift
diese größe kann man nicht übersehen
der chef der küstenwache sollte ins
gefängnis gesteckt
gegen den kapitän des frachters und den
chef der küstenwache wird mittlerweile
ermittelt unsere reporter annika rausch
und hannes radweg versuchten von den
arbeiten der einsatzkräfte der behörden
und der regierung auf mauritius zu
berichten und mehr licht ins dunkel zu
bekommen wie es zu diesem unglück kommen
konnte
daran werden sie aber aktuell gehindert
gelaufen zerbrochen ganz schweres
schwarzes öl tritt aus und die menschen
vor ort kämpfen ihnen gerade gegen diese
katastrophe
es gibt sogar frauen auf der insel die
mittlerweile ihr haar abschneiden um
damit das praktisch aufsaugen zu können
also die die insel hält zusammen und
kämpft gegen diese katastrophe und
darüber wollten wir berichten wollten
auf diese insel aber wir haben keine
chance denn auch corona ist hier
angekommen
der seeweg ist gesperrt und auch das
flugzeug schaffen wir es nicht oder per
hubschrauber
jeder weg darüber zu kommen ist eben
gesperrt hinzu kommt auch dass die
regierung sich dafür einsetzt dass keine
journalisten darüber berichten über
diese katastrophe weil sie natürlich
wieder urlauber zurückholen wollen
die die insel hatte natürlich auch
schwer mit der korona krise zu kämpfen
hatte keine touristen vor ort jetzt die
nächste katastrophe das meer ist dunkel
schwarz an der küste gerade diese eine
dieser einem küstenabschnitt ist
besonders beliebt bei touristen ist
paradiesisch weißer strand türkises meer
normalerweise ein paradies für alle
taucher nun diese katastrophe und darum
versuchen sie natürlich auch uns
journalisten nicht daran zu lassen damit
sie zum ersten september wieder die
touristen begrüßen können
wir haben auch mit einem mann gesprochen
der auf mauritius lebt und erst gesagt
für uns alle ist es die allergrößte
katastrophe